citizens of the reject Nation me terar
Ericson Gregory thought he was going to
talk and I'm like no just settle down
cuz you know what Greg he's sick but
he's got some stuff going on okay and I
have to shoot a film it's a sag low
budget okay it's an indie film so I'm
not against the strike because me love
SAG we got to roll through this this is
the only time we can do it so we're
rocking we're rolling yeah man yeah good
you did it you put the disclaimer out
there we appreciate it I did also guys
we're doing this despicable thing you
guys have all said Despicable three
that's what we're going to watch is like
maybe not the good one so is minions
good we'll see we'll see though minion
we need to know right us juice should we
do the Minions we're going to should we
do the Minions give us the juice should
we do it listen give us a juice send us
a like a comment type in there that you
love so much also ring the
bell ring the bell also if you're a
super sexy reack which means you're a
patron you get to watch the full
reaction sink up with your own copy like
it's a watch long with me and Greg and
you like one big happy family so if
you're not a patron get on top of it
John and Greg cover several shows
exclusively over there with highlights
and watch alongs included so you know
you get to see more of Greg and John
which I'm like I'm also here but like
it's fine you can get over there and
watch a lot of them I think that's it
also thanks to prepper for editing this
video we need to get into it let's watch
Dispicable Me Before Greg throws up and
before I have to be on set
[Music]
whoa this says is PG for nudity and
violence nudity weird and foul language
Guru is like look at my minion oh wow
yeah that's not the reaction no I I
really no one wants to see his minion
illuminat illuminat
that fart gun has really milked it I'm
half hoping that we think this is the
best
one yeah me too and we try to prove
everybody else wrong 1985 and the number
one show on TV was evil brat evil brat
cool alas are brats as a child prodigy
and criminal mastermind honestly this
looks like a show I'd watch I know right
but it all came to an end in season 3
when I've been a bad oh no puberty yikes
tough actually believe he was the
character he played on TV I've met these
people God where is he
now he's still running the streets of LA
in his purple tracksuit oh no's on boat
he's the villain playing a villain on TV
was fun but being one in real life life
is even better Heist music here it comes
what is that voice actor of him or the
robot the actual
guy cool still wearing purple all the
time I like
it nice
moves
whoa oh my God that's so dumb there's no
way there's no
way
H oh clever oh all right blow up
bubblegum is this guy like the dancing
villain like he's going to dance every
time he does some villainous stuff hey
I'm okay with it don't be cynical that'd
be awesome I'm okay with it I want every
agent in the area on the seed
immediately Finding Nemo oh no the
little fishy agents gruy are closing
fast yes wait what gruy grw and Lucy
mush together try it I like it but not a
lot I don't like
[Laughter]
it this one's a
3D cuz I'm bad I'm bad you know
it
wow this guy really rebounded after
being a failing
actor right
now it's it's kind Co wearing a stranger
thing shirt today considering is an 80s
guy
wow he's getting the way that's what he
thinks oh all right so hot Lucy all
right I don't think we can make it
through we can make
it we can make it
uh no how would you have grabbed onto
them yeah like there's nowhere to grab
on
to oh sweet sauce
nice good thinking Lucy that's great
transition how you
doing are you
okay
love that overconfidence you should be
on TV that's right you
are kick his ass
gr no he's going to he's going to out
dance him you know I go for the
hips wa it's at the Middle
Point wow that bald spot is blinding
Beggars can't be choosers ter did you
actually think I was unconscious it's
called acting hoser and clearly I've
still got
it I like this guy's
gadgetry sweet kear nudity yeah I've
been a bad
boy son of a BX the the animation just
keeps improving though this isn't over
grw I still have the diamond
[Music]
oh like they just landed on the beach
and then became like top DJs I love that
for them and they can pull off anything
oh
damn into the E into the
three again how is this possible
how
Trey Parker from South Park oh oh okay
it's not even worth talking about I
don't even want to was that's not so
secret man I feel like you would get
caught all the time doing that yeah
you're like plainly going into the sky
in a couch on a couch it is with great
sadness I am retiring as head of the AVL
no I loved you darn it don't you
remember him such big character left an
impression yeah head office effective
immediately oh wow all right long
legs blonde hair whoa Ambi what is going
here oh I mean someone finds her
attractive which one of you losers is
ancient grou that would be me how could
you let Bazar brat just get away that is
the opposite of what we do
here you did didn't get the diamond and
I am this close to bringing him in
interesting you're fired fired R is a
great agent you know what if you fire
him you're going to have to fire me
sister sister no we asking for it
they're asking for it by showing up out
of uniform they're literally the only
ones with normal clothes on everyone
else had a suit disrespect it was coming
is he going to have to go back to being
a villain M I would like that but then
he has to fight the okay he's got to out
fill in the dancer he's got to learn
dance moves I've
decided
hello well this one looks the best so
far waa that looks cool
yeah cool how cute you never got to go
on honeymoon so we made your dinner it's
aout oh my God so cute that's what
everyone wants in their honeymoon for
their children to be
there I love them the gummy bears were
my idea oh yummy a good old Gummy Bear
soup looks too good to even eat but I
made it for you you have to eat it you
better eat it g yeah you better she's so
adorable I love the combination
love gummy be
meat so how was work oh did you take
that guy down did anything explode well
actually they're careers Lucy and I were
invited to not work invited to not
work they're the best part of this oh my
God you could gamble online that's
Katie's dad does that's a good
suggestion and let's not go over to
Katie's house
anymore I know it's been a little tough
lately especially with Dr nefario
accidentally freezing himself in
carbonite what a dude poor guy they
could not a very good scientist couldn't
get Russell Brand to commit to being on
set
[Music]
go dark let's for lunch be bad we're not
going back to villain and I don't want
to hear another word about
it ciao Bell you're serious come
on yeah stop on that hat oh boy you're
in charge now
h i mean if he just gets that one guy
he'd be able to get his job back right
but he doesn't have any dance skills and
purple tracksuit guys got a
lot they keep getting bigger I know they
make a lot of fat jokes in this the
chief of police sent me he was concerned
that during the recent Hast attempt the
Dumont Diamond was replaced you could
hear him jiggling you have been deep
what by me oh it's fake he's the guy he
is an
actor oh
[Music]
no oh okay oh no oh
oh got
it huh I've been a bad boy or should I
say I mean he seems like a really
competent villain though yeah like a
difficult one to take down like it's
like all really easy for him a true
Anarchist I'm waiting for this movie to
get terrible yeah me too and so far I'm
like this is about on part with what I
know for Despicable Me yeah I feel
like lost a
failure a like I don't have a purpose
anymore welcome to my weekly
crisis it's daily for me well that makes
sense looking at you
you should feel like with
her EXC me pardon
me people there's a lot more texture in
this animation like darkness and shadows
like yeah it's more
striking I didn't know that the dog's
name was Kyle until just now helps you
if you have Nightmare and he's really
good to snuggle with Agnes Agnes no not
the big fluffy unicorn she giving away
her stuff no sweet girl I just wanted to
help since you don't have a job she is
the best character in this whole
franchise she really is I would never
sell anything to help out her get off
the lawn yeah but hey could you of
course no as I was saying I uh oh
goodbye uh the villain is coming oh my
god wow just murder that guy he just
killed that guy I feel like they also
killed that guy in that car earlier too
oh good he's not dead my name is
CH and I am inquiring on behalf of your
twin brother Drew he needs your help
Drew what your father has recently
passed away I'm sorry but my dad died
when I was a baby huh how do you explain
this
you oh MRE what did you do oh my God
he's so much more successful holy to
Molly oh there's a mom just lounging
around never
mind it's important to keep active in
one's Golden
Years
wow mommy oh my goodness I have a twin
brother how did you find out it's true
didn't even try to lie that was the
agreement what are you talking about oh
she gets one he gets the other your
father and I divorced we each took one
son to raise on our own and promised
never to see each other again
interesting to throw a divorce element
into a kid movie I don't really hear
that too often yeah Alo that's sad I
have a
brother I don't think I would care if
you had a twin brother yeah you would
you'd be like let me just get a look at
him we don't need to have a relationship
but like you really look like me or what
does he do reactions CU of what does he
do hi piggy
piggy whoa look at that house oh my god
well if my twin brother live like that I
want to go meet him what's with all the
pigs this is the family business the
largest pig farm in the whole of are you
doing here they're into making bacon oh
who this is amazing that looks pretty
awesome uh what have you done I mean I'm
down my
[Music]
brother
Dre oh no oh my God he's even got a full
head of hair wow you must be the
beautiful wife beautiful oh oh she would
totally go for him oh yeah you're this
you're small with big eyes and it makes
me want to put you in my pocket you
can't do that I'm too
big and Margo oh you are so mature I'm
guessing why you 15 15 she's 12 she
looks 12 and will always be 12 yeah
creepy place is amazing sure I'm not
really into
things oh my gosh why are they not pink
they're all red is he laundering drugs
through those pigs ooh a little cocaine
all right let's go home now home why I
don't know this guy with the mansion and
the cars and all the hair he's jealous
you could kill him and take his identity
yeah you girl should go with FL bye you
boys have
[Music]
fun you know people clown on 1% centers
all the time as terrible people but it'
be nice to be like a five for Center or
something you
know a five
forent and the all new Mega Diamond
laser oh wow this guy's got his own toys
and stuff evil brat was a masterpiece
it's a disgrace and a travesty sir this
time I'm cancelling you and all the
losers who rejected me oh no we live
there wow not good to watch while
there's a strike going on
true is it broken
[Music]
oh oh how cool would that be what is all
this the pig farm looks like Harry
Potter
Chambers his
laugh
what very creative set in layers and
he's a criminal yeah no no no not just a
villain but one of the greatest super
super super villain the bald
Terror more like bald D I feel like he
never went full bald to D I was just a
failure never thought I had what it took
to be a villain wow interesting ju the
position they're drawing here teach me
the art of
villainy no I left that life behind me
end the story I wonder what this
does oh is he going to hold them as
collateral this
holy moly dad's villain Wheels oh so
this one's combining the super villainy
and the super spy stuff yeah all into
one big mumbo jumbo What a Beautiful Day
Z to 43 seconds able to withand a
nuclear blast I'm to the
te whoa It's a
hybrid he said it's a hybrid
[Music]
Oh I thought they were going to go in
the water and swim around a
bit I mean the animation of visuals are
still very cool pretty it's pretty cool
I like the point of view of the camera
too yeah the way they lock off the shots
are really awesome I am not enjoying
[Applause]
this who the Drew guy is a little
annoying though yeah absolutely 100%
welcome to the annual fredonian cheese
festival
go what that where how do I go to there
that seems insanely dangerous can we get
these
please okay but only one each
a no I don't you want I don't
care it's okay to tell them no sometimes
too you know not when you're trying to
get love she is wearing a Grinch T-shirt
she is made after my own heart can we go
in
there you don't want to go in there I
love
this the little girls go and get the
cheese oh my God amazing you just walk
around and eat cheese all
day a look at that poor little guy
nobody picked him go pick him why don't
you go up there go take a bite of his
cheese young lady right now starting
with the one who gave you permission to
say no
yeah I'm Margo hello
Margo I am ni it's like a little
grou thank you thank
you I am a great mother did you see that
girls I oh they're gone they're in there
drinking with those cowboys
look a unicorn
horn it's real all right came from the
Crooked Forest where unicorns still
live you crazy French freaks oh my god
oh boy oh I saw one once did you it did
it smell like candy was
it I thought I was is going to die that
he said he said the L yeah it's so
fluffy I want to die they say if I made
in pure of heart goes into the Crooked
Forest the Unicorn will come and be hers
wow
AG oh my goodness excuse me girls don't
worry I'm here are you
okay unicorns are really real I'm going
to fight
one I love her so much I hope this
unicorn is actually real me too this is
the adventure I want to go on is them
trying to find a
unicorn what are you
doing did you just steal candies yes
that's a lot of effort for two
lollipops the police what do we do what
we do come on oh he's kicking the he's
getting the spark
all right I'm
down bringing out pigs no not the
pigs cops and
[Music]
pigs whoa
uh-oh oh it's going to turn into a boat
right yeah yeah cool I thought you were
going to pee your pants I did you
did I mean the movie's cool cute and fun
it's not like mesmerizing or something
[Music]
yeah
Pizza why does it look like the Warner
Brothers lot yeah it does right saw side
like I'm pretty sure I just saw a Vin
Diesel cameo in the background H really
yeah
[Music]
oh oh my
God love how they're not perturbed At
All by whatever the hell these things
are
[Music]
right
this movie is so Random there so many
things happening yeah there's three
different story
lines four oh the minions are in
Hollywood we got the brat guy we got
Lucy kg I forgot about that guy he
hadn't been around in a
minute a lovely amazing wait when I use
the bathroom my toilet paper always
turns pink after I use it oh or some
kind of red yeah I feel like I don't we
don't need to really um discuss it it's
been like that for days oh yeah become
grew again how awesome would that be oh
please come on oh I hope this movie does
something really strange and has them
fall in
love just go for it be
weird that you still want the Ste
there is something what do you want to
steal what we steal the largest diamond
in oh from yeah all right and then
return it I'm finally going to get to
see a unicorn there was a chance did you
might not find one it might not be good
unicorn finding weather why are you
disappointing her beforehand maybe
unicorns don't
exist exist explore that part of the
woods I made could find one if she was
pure and heart I'm pure and heart right
yeah the purest the
purest if I have a daughter and she
doesn't end up like her yeah you cancel
it throw it in trash throw it out throw
that daughter out absolutely right in
the trash either into the trash or the
recycling either one of them will do
just send her somewhere
else oh my goodness this I love get that
[Laughter]
back look at him snapping their way
through is this their version of
Westside Story with
minions oh my God they run this person
love it they run it because they are
true villains look at him looking at the
camera oh my goodness can't the minions
have taking over but
[Music]
banana gr what you saw Gru there wait
what oh
pdsd a see gr always loved them time to
watch a very special episode of evil
brat to see exactly what I'm going to do
to stupid tensil Town God how's this guy
not gotten over his TV show from 20
years ago like come on buddy chew on
[Music]
this
he's shooting his super sticky
self-inflating
gum oh
[Music]
goodness now that's Entertainment come
on let's make it a reality I will be
honest that studio is pretty cool his
style I like it I know I don't like him
I'm going to film it and get rich look
over
there holy moly that is gorgeous
unicorns here we come they love candy
what's that for f that looks like a
Simpsons uh donut this is brat it may
not look like there's so many plots
happening so much going on also where is
like Margo and Mom and those kids are
just like allowed to go out solo
apparently into the woods that's crazy
to me climb up to the cube and enter
here and once I'm inside find the
diamond I think we can have
it Dad villain suits this will make us
Unstoppable oh I you w i call the black
one I really feel like they could have
done a lot more with the Drew character
though yeah he's just kind of like loud
and annoying yeah he's not really I
don't really know him as a personality
other they're just like the same and
kind of yeah hello Mother Amaro I am
Nico I present you with big to confirm
my my engagement to your daughter
engagement oh that's what eating the
cheese meant and nobody knew it it's not
happening who was I kidding a dumpling
like me with a goddess like you I will
never forget you Marco oh I'm pretty
sure I won't forget you either planed
not work you you refuse my son's
engagement big may you and your daughter
Die slow death and be buried with onions
oh no they're cursed you do not want to
mess with me do you understand me yes
yes good I think we just need to oh okay
that seemed like too easy like the
payoff wasn't good enough yeah right
like I'm really starting to feel the
movie's weaknesses yeah it's F it's a
fine movie so far it's fine yeah it's
fine I'm not like I'm mostly excited for
this plot point and the minions those
are my
favorite my whole life has been building
to this moment
[Applause]
[Music]
uh what just a goat it's a
unicorn love that I can't believe
it that is so adorable so cute and she's
allowed to bring it home still don't see
why I can't go with you now is not the
time to mess with the
plant hey father saw that
coming
help
me oh my God he's making so much
[Music]
noise oh
boy come
on camouflage
B please and close your eyes and cover
your
mouth you should have stayed in the
boat like how this look like a video
game oh my God
okay all
right follow
me oh no oh
uh-oh
you this guy is such a liability it's
going so wrong all
wrong
oh hey hey he slightly contributed
something are they doing a prison break
uh oh they can just go right
through oh are they creating a flying
device oh
interesting
awesome
wait what is thaty going to how what's
he going to do did he just
left no what about him why you still
have one of
these wait what just happening I don't
know this guy just doesn't know how to
be a villain we get it but I'm like
would he really be that dumb that's
exploding Bubblegum
don't do
it oh
boy look at it CLI it's beautiful oh he
did bring it to life oh all right you sh
up he's going to spot
us gross open your mouth oh
God Intruders
Intruders freeze GR
there's two of you now and this will be
twice as much fun I like how you can
recognize him right
away yeah it took him like a0 five
seconds to be like gr give me back my D
go get him Brad
pack
oh a lot of these
semi uh the crass humor
jokes don't you
stick yeah sticky okay they're just
going to happen to miss
a hey guys what oh we got the diamond
and we're going to take it do the AVL
and get our jobs back you'll never ever
go behind my back every ever again okay
that was really convenient yeah it was
no way we can't give the diamond back I
have to oh no is he going to partner up
with Brady oh and become a True Villain
at least I had the job what have you
accomplished it was so great I'll tell
you what nothing no wonder Dad thought
you were such a failure dude too mean we
are no longer brothers that's fine with
me we are enemies gr I found a unicorn I
like how they they still call him grw
instead of Dad yeah right that's not
actually a unicorn but he has one horn
life is just like that sometimes we're
hoping for a unicorn and we get a goat
that goat is so adorable lucky is the
best goat in the whole world world
that's right Agnes you could learn
something from her attitude who I'll
take this can you get the rest of the
suitcases come on girls let's go let's
get physical physical I want
to change of plans girls instead of
going home
what we're going to
Hollywood that was a good twist oh yeah
let's go Clive we've got a giant robot
waiting that was really well done yeah I
like that
Lucy brat he took the girls what no this
time it's Persona Drew go away I don't
want to t you but he needs your help
now no I'm
sorry I'm so sorry grw oh look out what
is
that oh what are the
odds oh
boy
yay go get
him wow great design of those
clouds oh boy wow that looks very
tangible that looks real giant robot
that does not that looks that looks
great yeah
hello Hollywood not technically
Hollywood because you did arise in Santa
Monica but I guess he moves fast I was
wonder if that was Santa Monica per it
was good old Hollywood and Highland is
going up in
bubbles oh
no oh no what in the
world oh is that supposed to that is so
mean lights camera
bler oh oh this is not
good this is actually Hollywood all
these buildings are in the right place
crazy look I've got the girls you two go
take care of brat damn you're able to
spot them all right man what is does she
oh okay show that you're a good mom I
love it when a plan comes together a
it's oh is that the voice of the Family
Guy guy no I think it's the South Park
guy the South Park guy yeah that guy
Trey Parker I just heard it right
[Music]
now okay that was easy the design of
that looks so like oh real it actually
looks real yeah Brad pack go get that
back oh
incoming well
[Music]
uh oh so
annoying I swear drewy you better save
the
day get um there you go now he's coming
into His True Villain skills cuz he's
fighting for something bigger than
himself hang on girls I got you
I'm oh no oh my goodness oh God him good
job
Lucy
whoa look at what we have
here all right save your twin
brother oh my God you got to climb fast
oh boy hurry up just cut them all cut
them
all what's happening
go we're going to get out of there
Drew uh-oh he's going to blow up
buddy that looks pretty cool though now
it's time to die any last words grw I
got two words for you dance fight here
we go oh unlike K we knew that we knew
this was going to
happen
you're love to
me
yeah come on
G all right come on come on G let's get
rid of this
guy what you're looking
[Music]
for bitching die by bitching classical
Rocky talk
or onions it's not there's no way it's
that easy oh
what how are these weapons not working
against these bubbles these poor
[Laughter]
minions Soul where it says soul in the
background like a billboard oh like for
that movie that Pixar
movie
It's Raining Men hallelujah it's
[Music]
raining love you mom say hi to gr for
me go go to
bed to sleep with the minions you have a
perfectly nice mansion guys come on oh
boy
he has an
umbrella oh my God wait what is this I
think they go do villainy stuff I
thought we said no more villainy
somebody's got to keep the family
tradition alive
right oh they all suits too let's get
him he's my brother we'll give him a 5
minute headit
start wow what a weird battle to be
embroiled into too yeah fighting your
twin brother my brother/ roommate I have
to fight every single
night
just every night he comes home to the
same house and they're like love you
brother and then he's like I'm off to do
villainy all right five minute Head
Start that sounds like a nightmare yeah
I mean this movie was fine I still
thought it was fun my favorite plot
points are always the minions and
obviously Agnes trying to find the
Unicorn if we could have stayed with
them I would have really I would have
loved it I mean it's not like bad I just
I there were times I was sitting here
just going like I don't know why oh is
that a put no it's a regular I don't
know why it's
not it wasn't as like there was too many
plot points and at no point was there
any emotions pulling me into being like
Oh it's so sweet besides Agnes she's
always the one who's so sweet and makes
me like oh that's like really sweet I
really felt something other than that I
just sort of was like yeah okay I'm
watching a a thing like yeah no it
actually I agree it this was this
definitely was diminishing returns like
it looks yeah like in the beginning we
kind of thought it might be good yeah in
the beginning I was like I don't know
what people are talking about this is
like really fun and we're setting up a
villain right off the bat and he wins
and he causes G to lose his job and I
thought that they were setting up a lot
of great ways to continue forward but it
it definitely felt like whoa what's
going on here oh know just uh all right
there's stuff on screen happening with
them whatever um yeah know it it was
these are really cool credits they are
distracting me but they're really cool
they're cool it's like what they did
with the mins in the last one yes um
it's just whenever it feels like I'm
watching a mid credit scene it's not a
mid credit scene it's just them chasing
each other it's just that running around
okay I'll try not to be distracted by it
um yeah but as it progressed I I still I
just didn't really connect with anything
um me neither it it it just kind of felt
like like this the last movie sequel
felt like a a a proper progression for
Gru and where his journey would take him
and this felt like they were making
up to make a movie you know I mean yeah
like they're just like add this plat
Point add this plat point and at even as
we got to like where they're trying to
go and break into the into the the the
purple guy's house whatever I just felt
like kind of numb watching it like even
those those parts about him being sticky
being camouflag is supposed to be funny
they're going together he's like I
didn't feel anything I was like I don't
even find this really that funny but
maybe it's because I don't know we
didn't set up enough with Drew the
brother we didn't really get to know him
that much we get that he was like kind
of the sweeter one and he he wants to be
a villain but um I don't know I don't
know like what it he's really annoying
though yeah I know it's too many it's
way too much grw Drew energy like
because they're very similar that I'm
like oh God thank God we're cutting to a
minion scene or like thank goodness it's
the girls now um and I still felt like
the the plot of like Margot being thrown
in there with eating the cheese and and
Lucy having to stick up to uh to the
kids to to the family to become like
more of her mom and a mom figure we
didn't even really still set that up it
was like literally just a line in the
beginning of like I'm still getting used
to the mother daughter stuff and then
just cut to her being like go eat that
cheese and then they she saves them at
the end and Agnes calls her mom normally
in that part in a movie that was set up
well with great Foundation when the
little girl rolls over and says I love
you mom for the first time you would
probably feel something or be like close
to tears I didn't really feel much cuz I
was like we didn't do there was way too
many plot points it felt like everything
sort of got half measured out you know
they there was the plot line with Drew
and grew which uh I I think definitely
needed a little bit more meat on it than
like I never felt like I guess grw
needed a brother and then it didn't even
really lead to an arc yeah it just was
like he was just there yeah like they
they got to the point because the whole
thing with Drew being a wanting to be a
villain got introduced like a little bit
past the Midway Point uh but you know
guo goes over there and he wants to meet
his brother and then he just now he has
a brother and that was about it yeah
there was a little bit of a conflict for
like two minutes when you know he's that
would be disappointing you but then the
girls got kidnapped so that was resolved
and right away and they started working
together
instantaneously and Drew is just kind of
loud and obnoxious and then uh the story
with like there's stuff about the
stories that I don't feel like the the
theme of the movie was even that clear I
kind of just felt like stuff was
happening you know um where the first
one about being a father and realiz
that's more important then the second
one was Finding Love yeah and and then
this one was like what exactly wasn't
about it we don't even know like all
that stuff with Margo and and the
getting engaged just felt like sketch
comedy uh didn't really matter and it
was it felt Half Baked half half cooked
and even Agnes with the Unicorn bit was
like what did it really amount to uh it
was just like a thing for them to do
yeah like another because they were like
we don't have enough to write a good
enough movie that's just about this and
then they set it up with the villain um
to try to provide I guess a met meta
angle to it but I would forget about him
I would totally forget he's in this
movie that's why when I was like there's
three plot points you're like there's
four and I still didn't go like oh right
I went uh and then you had to explain it
because I forgot about that guy yeah in
the beginning I thought he was going to
be really likable and and something I
didn't like him he was uh he
just was he he kind of annoying too I
didn't leave much yeah he's a little
Annoying I prefer watching him over Drew
yeah I I agree and he's um
um yeah I mean I like the one little
twist where he he was posing as
Lucy but other than and like the visuals
were really great again but when the
story weaknesses really stand out and
and you're just not feeling much for it
the visuals can only do so much to make
up for that when the visuals are not
like it's not like watching spiderverse
or something where they're just like
it's so insanely good that you know that
it's that it's a voice of its own uh
that that's not the case here it it felt
yeah it it definitely felt like they
were I really felt like the sequel the
last one even though I didn't preferred
over the first movie was still a real
natural way this felt like they were
just trying to cash in on some that
they didn't really need to yeah it it
felt like all the higher ups got around
and was like throw this in and I want
this and this and we here's your money
but do this oh here's a good script but
nope we should have this this and this
and then they were like here you go and
they went yeah make that and I'm like
did nobody screen this prior to be like
what is an audience reaction going to be
because I feel like most people would be
like it was okay but they probably
wouldn't walk away going it was good but
then again like I'm just thinking with
an animation you can literally cut
scenes and draw new stuff so like you
know what I mean like I mean it takes a
long time to like R all that well
that's true the thing is Despicable Me
came out in what 2010 if I'm not
mistaken it's 2017 and people who if if
you're if your only target audience's
kids you should I think a lot of times
you got to be factoring in uh the fact
that people will be growing up you know
and yeah they're true it's like seven
years have passed growing up with it
yeah yeah and like even the little girls
don't feel like they grow just feels
like they don't they're always the same
age there's this passage of time clearly
yeah from Gru to then guu meeting Lucy
then grew getting married and then
they're positioned in the job like
there's clearly a passage of time and it
feels like exact days yeah yeah they're
the exact same age like they don't seem
like they grew up at all right and I
think that would have aided it as
opposed to just putting them in like a
funny scenario really dealing a little
bit more with that side bringing it back
full circle to them having to be parents
in a way instead of this random brother
element that I did not think helped
aided I didn't care I would have rather
seen more family stuff like them
becoming more of a family and how do we
get past her thing of like becoming a
mom and like maybe the minions teach
them something because the Min there was
that one little clip of the minion being
like but Gru are dad right and he thinks
back he looks at the bubbles on the
ground and we're like what is that and
was like they didn't even Circle back to
that like real really sweet Montage of
like he's a dad also to these minions
but they got upset cuz they're like
you're a real vain and you're not
anymore whatever but they never even
really went back to that and I would
have liked to follow that cuz that kind
of made me feel something like that he's
a dad to the minions he's a dad to the
girls and now he has his wife to to
bring into the picture but it it was
just sort of like no we got to do like
spy action stuff and I just didn't I
don't know I didn't care you're so right
about that because when that moment
happened I thought I was thinking this
is really interesting yeah because the
minions you you kind of just lump them
all together even though there's ones
like I don't know Kevin and whatever Mel
they all have some of them have names
but they don't have distinct
personalities I don't know who's going
to get mad at me for saying that but
they really don't guys they all kind of
blend together right um and I thought oh
they're really G to make this one
distinct like this one we're going to
get the most connected to yeah there was
actually going to be a true emotional
connection because he's going to be the
one who is not for what everyone else is
for right now and he wants to get back
to gr and I thought they were really
going to do something with that so that
you had like that one minion you really
connected to and I completely forgot
about it until you brought it up right
now and I don't even know that it was
the same cuz there's the thing and when
he looks down at the bubbles he didn't
have the little hairs on the side of his
head he was just bald I think and then
it cuts to like the guy with the side
hair with fishing and then a different
one with different hair in the different
part of the Montage so it was like a
display of like oh he's been a father
figure to all the Minions at some point
right and does stuff with them I guess
fun things but yeah we we never got back
to it and I'm like that's a story I
would I would follow along with him like
having to raise his daughters who should
be getting older yeah you know yeah I
don't know I mean uh like I I there's I
what we're talking about is all the the
great misp potential and the things that
were yeah that stood out as weak yeah
but but the actual experience you know
honestly if I was if we weren't I think
if we didn't have a camera pointer at us
and we were just like friends hanging
out and watching we were like yeah it
was fine yeah it's fine we wouldn't be
like picking it apart that but this is
what we do here I guess when it's like
we're supposed to do we're supposed to
we're supposed to review it and and as
going through it of what what we thought
was the weak points I'm like yeah these
are the weak points about it but the but
the movie itself is is just like no it's
just a fine
I I am disappoint I got to admit though
I am disappointed because of the fact
that you know it when it's a first movie
I I let that excuse slide way more where
you're just like it's a kids movie yeah
yeah it's a kids movie when it's the
first one but when you have like two
like really good ones prior yeah that
makes it really disappointing and I
can't just chalk it up to it's a kids
movie at that point no it's like it was
thrown together for the sake of earning
money but like I I just think I think
it's weird because I tend to really like
a lot of universal films and I I feel
like they've done a good job in making
films throughout the years and I don't
feel like they do a lot of that what we
just saw here where it's like just thr
it together we have a name and a thing
and a theme park and people love minions
that I'm like what no all always only
make really good stuff even if you they
started feeling like oh we sell the
brand yeah yeah whereas the the second
one felt like an I heard the second one
actually got like a best pitcher
nomination so for the animated
Department oh that one's a well put
together movie yeah and this felt like
kind of like it belongs on a streaming
service yeah it felt like a not not
released into a thing like if for you to
watch and maybe come and go as you're
making dinner if you're not that
interested in yeah this felt like a
straight to streaming service kind of
movie um I give it five out of 10 five
.5 maybe I'll meet you right there we
didn't rate any of the other ones but
we'll rate this one we'll rate we'll
rate this one I mean and also you guys
got to let us know if you want us to
watch the Minions movies or other stuff
kind kind of did kill my buzz for it
yeah I know right we're I think we might
have to move on to a different type of
genre of film for a while unless you
guys are like minions are the best you
have no idea how good the Minions movie
is there's going to be a comments that
are like minions are bust yeah oh my
goodness minions are be
unsubscribed don't do that we love you
too much this channel is horror animated
and action
movies it is lately horror animated
action no consistent genre no not at all
not true okay well we love you guys
leave that like leave the comment ring
the bells do all the stuff if you're not
a patron become one and I think that's
it that's it we love you
goodbye
[Music]
banana